اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاده
ثلاثه فلسطينيين برصاص جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي شمال الضفه وكان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قد اعلن صباح اليوم انه قتل
ثلاثه فلسطينيين واعتقل رابعا خلال اشتباك
مسلح عند مفرق قريه جيت قرب نابلس واكد
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي ان قوات
الاحتلال صادرات ثلاثه بنادق من نوع ام 16
وذخيره كانت بحوزه المسلحين من جهه قال
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ان وحده النخبه في
الجيش الاسرائيلي بولاني نفذت ما وصفها
بعمليه حازمه ودقيقه في المنطقه
ينضم الينا من نابلس مراسلنا سمير ابو
شمال سمير اذا نابلس مره اخرى وثلاثه
شهداء هذا الصباح
نعم صحيح نحن الان نتواجد في موقع اغتيال
ثلاثه مسلحين من المقاومه الفلسطينيه فجر
هذا اليوم هذه القصه بدات وفقا لروايات
شهود العيان بجيش جنود من الجيش الاحتلال
نصبه كمينا في هذا هذه الشقه السكنيه
المطله على الشارع القريب من الحاجز
العسكري لحاجز صرا العسكري غربي مدينه
نابلس الاحتلال ما ان وصلت سياره التي
كانت تقل المسلحين الاربعه في هذا المكان
وقفت في هذا موقع تحديدا وخرج المسلحون
منها وبغثتهم قوات الاحتلال بالرصاص وقتلت
ثلاثه منهم ولكن كان احدهم في داخل
السياره تم تصفيته واثنان اخران مسلحان
قتلتهما قوات الاحتلال في هذا الموقع
تحديدا الموجود في الشاشه وايضا على بعد
عده امتار كان هناك شهيد الثالث قتلته
قوات الاحتلال وهناك اثار للدماء لهذا
الشهيد الثالث في هذه العمليه بينما
اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه المسلح
الرابع الذي كان
مقتبعا في هذا المكان بالتحديد
واعتقلته واحتجزت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه الشهداء المسلحين الثلاثه
التي لم تعلن حتى هذه اللحظه هويه الشهداء
الثلاثه بشكل رسمي هناك اسماء متداوله في
نابلس ولكن حتى الان لم تعلن الاسماء
الرسميه من قبل المصادر الطبيه الرسميه
اللجنه التنسيق الفصائل في مدينه نابلس
اعلنت الحداد العام على ارواح الشهداء
الثلاثه الذين سقطوا برصاص جيش الاحتلال
الايطاليه الجيش الاحتلال يتحدث بانه هناك
الحاجز سر العسكري القريب من هذا المكان
وعاده ما
يقوم المسلحون من
المجموعات عرين الاسود وغيرهم باطلاق
الرصاص عليه على هذه الحواجز المحيطه
بمدينه نابلس وفي هذا المكان حسب روايات
شهود العين كثير ما يتواجد جنود الاحتلال
يقومون بنصب الكمائن في هذا المكان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بان قوه من لواء الجولاني
قد
كمنت او اقامت كمين نصبت لهذه المجموعه
المسلحه واطلقت النار عليها وعثرت على
بحوزتهم على ثلاثه
قطع من السلاح من نوع سته عشر وايضا ذخيره
في السياره وغيرها واحتجزت الشهداء
الثلاثه في نابلس هناك حداد في هذه
الاثناء وقد ارتفعت حصيره الشهداء منذ
بدايه هذا العام حسب مصادر الطبيه
الفلسطينيه الرسميه الى 84 شهيدا بينهم
خمسه عشر طفلا بينما تحتجز قوات الاحتلال
حتى هذه اللحظه اكثر من 130 جثمانا لديها
في ثلاجات الموتى
شكرا لك سمير ابو شماله مراسلنا من نابلس